coastal at one moment isolated island at  another mall say Michelle is incredibly  stunning  no matter the tide in between two  powerful tides from Normandy and  Brittany stands the Gothic styled  Benedictine abbey named after and  dedicated to the Archangel Saint Michael  Monte Michel wasn't always an island in  prehistoric times it stood on dry land  however as sea levels rose erosion  reshaped the coast even today it only  sits 600 metres from land although it  has less than 50 full-time residents it  is visited by more than 3 million people  each year the climb to see the Abbey  isn't easy it's around 900 steps  more than just a church on Iraq  malsu Michel is a medieval time capsule  and was one of the first monuments to be  classed as a UNESCO World Heritage Site  back in 1979  [Music]